alright thank you for having me here I'm
Marcus I just started a lab at NYU
School of Medicine I was also a loose
sigler fellow with Anastasia at
Princeton before going there and what my
lab is interested in is how proteins
interact with their targets so I'm
actually an experimentalist and this
talk will be a lot different from some
of the talks that we've already seen so
we're interested in protein interactions
of protein-dna interactions or protein
protein interactions we might be
engineering those interactions for a
synthetic biology application or we
might be trying to characterize those
interactions for more systems or network
applications either way we're interested
in the nuts and the bolts of these sorts
of interactions and today I'm going to
talk about trying to find functional but
low affinity interactions and the reason
for this is we're finding more and more
in biology that they're very meaningful
low affinity interactions so for example
Mike Levine recently published a paper
about what he called sub optimal binding
sites and how those relate to
transcription there are a number of
protein-protein interactions that have
been reported that are involved in
signaling pathways where turnover is
very important so high affinity
interactions can actually slow down that
turnover but my favorite example comes
from the labs of david stern and richard
mann where they're talking about homeo
domains which are very near and dear to
my heart and it addresses this paradox
in the homeodomain so there are many
different homeo domains and they're very
important in development in determining
the body plan but for the most part
whether they're binding oops whether
they're binding as a monomer or in a
complex they bind very very similar
sequences so how is it that these
proteins are able to control very
different functions in very different
developments when they're all binding to
the same things and what what dr. Mann
and CERN found was that the
high-affinity interactions all of the
homeodomain zar binding to those
sequences
it's the low-affinity interactions that
are discriminating between an
interaction with one homeodomain versus
another so it turns out that the very
functional and very important
interactions can be the low-affinity
interactions so if our techniques to
characterize these interactions are
biased towards affinity we're losing a
huge picture of the puzzle and this this
becomes evident when we look at many of
the common techniques that we use to
characterize these interactions like sea
legs and phage display are techniques
that are used that they use men multiple
rounds of selection or multiple rounds
of enrichment that lead to a consensus
and ultimately these are higher affinity
interactions so we're losing lower
affinity interactions and then there are
other methods like hybrid assays and
protein binding microarrays where you
set some threshold and you're going to
lose the interactions below that
threshold and just recover what's above
that threshold if you set that threshold
very low it can be difficult to discern
what is a functional and and a non
functional interaction so just to sort
of sum that up if we're using a
technique they in riches for something
we are leading towards high affinity
interactions if you're using a technique
that sets a threshold it can be hard to
discern functional from non functional
interactions so what my lab works on is
an old technique that we try and modify
we use a hybrid assay and we use a
bacterial hybrid a say that I've been
working on since I was in graduate
school so to explain what we're trying
to do I'm just going to give a review a
small little review of hybrid acids I'm
sure you're all familiar with but just
to make some points the idea behind just
about any hybrid is that you have some
gene that is your reporter gene and this
is something that we measure or that we
can measure and we're trying to make the
output of this gene a meaningful
representation of the interaction that
we're interested in that might be a
protein DNA interaction or it might be a
protein-protein interaction so in this
example we have a known protein DNA and
interaction a known protein-protein
interaction and we ask the
do these two proteins interact with one
another if they do this whole you know
Bala of stuff gets recruited to the
promoter in turns on your reporter which
is again something that you can measure
now we have all kinds of different
reporters that one might use there are
selectable reporters like his three and
your three and the beauty of a
selectable reporter is you can screen
through very large libraries to find
potentially rare variants that actually
interact with one another because you
can make survival of these cells
dependent on that interaction so that
it's a great screening method
alternatively scalable reporters like
gfp be they have different levels of
output so the amount of that output can
tell you something about the strength of
the interaction that you're you're
interested in now you can do hybrid
essays and all kinds of cell types we
like bacteria because it's very easy to
use it's very fast and probably the only
person who thinks that yeast are too
slow but we the main reason that we like
bacteria is the ten to the ninth
transformation efficiency so this means
that in a single eppendorf I can look at
a billion combination so this level of
throughput really lends itself to you
know the kind of systems level
experiments that were interested in okay
so we use a bacterial system and to
explain how this works I'm going to go
back to the very beginning and Scott
wolf slab where I did my graduate work
and the the development of this specific
version of a hybrid system where it
started there was to characterize the
transcription factor specificity or the
DNA binding specificity of different
transcription factors so how this works
is we express the DNA binding domain or
a factor of interest as a direct fusion
to the Omega subunit of bacterial
polymerase that just functions as our
activation domain then we place a region
of random sequences upstream of the
promoter that regulates our reporters
which are history and your three from
yeast we do this in a bacterial strain
where we've knocked out the equivalence
of these reporters so that when we grow
these cells on media that lacks
histidine survival is independent
activation of this gene and therefore
dependent on this protein DNA
interaction now like I said before some
methods have different thresholds that
you can set we can set our threshold
using three amino triazole or 380 which
is a competitive inhibitor of history in
order to require more or less history to
be expressed and then presumably a
higher low affinity interaction now the
the greatest advantage of this system
relative to any other hybrid SI is is
omega and i think this is often
overlooked and that is because omega is
part of the core polymerase but it's
non-essential so we can do our
selections in a strain where we have
knocked out the endogenous omega so when
we're expressing our fusion protein
we're recruiting polymerase to the
promoter that we care about the one
promoter that is driving this reporter
without any competition from omega in
the cell because we knocked it out so
other hybrid assays you may be familiar
with it's very common to have to express
your fusion protein at such a level that
it's actually toxic to the cell we don't
have that problem because we lack this
competition and in fact i'm showing you
here a Western of three different fusion
protein that we expressed with three
different promoters and it's actually
this weakest promoter is the promoter
that we most often use so we can really
dial back the protein expression level
in the system and we still get a strong
output of our reporters and that just
tells you we get a more sensitive
readout of these interactions now in
practice what we do is we transform two
plasmids into our cell line and we're
doing this in such a way that a single
member of your library will get into
each cell so the cell purely it
functions as a compartment it's
compartmentalizing a single member of
your library with the protein that
you're interested in if that's a
compatible interaction the cell will
survive under selective conditions if
it's not a compatible interaction the
cell doesn't survive so once you grow
them under selective conditions you you
recover those colonies and then you
sequence the window of the plasma that
had been randomized and you can get a
representation
and of what sequences were required for
that salt to survive which represents
the DNA binding specificity of the
transcription factor since Scott has
gone on and now characterized over half
of the transcription factor is intro
safa low using this method I've done a
lot more stuff engineering with this
bacterial system but to give you a sense
of the throughput a technician in my lab
can do 25 selections per week so it's
it's relatively high throughput now
something I worked on with Mona's saying
who is not here yet is we actually flip
this system around because it's on
plasmids it's very easy to do this so
that we can change the bait in the prey
combination so it's just as easy to
express a library of proteins and select
those that are able to interact with the
target that you're interested in and we
did that by screening some enormous zinc
finger libraries over a comprehensive
set of DNA targets and produce the
largest combination of zinc finger
positive zinc finger DNA interactions
today but I'm not going to talk about
that today maybe Mona will but what I
want to talk about is how we're we're
manipulating this system to now capture
the low end of affinity so like I said
before we have two reporters here
selectable reporters history followed by
year three but you're a three is really
just a historical at this point it
doesn't even need to be there for this
application so what we did was we
replaced it with gfp with the idea that
if we combine a selectable with a
scalable reporter that we could start by
screening through large libraries to
find functional interactions and then
sorting based on the GFP output to get
an idea of what the strength of that
interaction is so just giving you an
example with protein-dna interactions
what we've done is we just did a mock
experiment where we tried ziff 268 a
very commonly used zinc finger protein
with a set of binding sites that have
known affinities relative to the
consensus target and without any
selection we just screw these cells
and measured the GFP output and you can
see that the GFP output is nicely
related to the affinities of these
different binding sites but what was
most impressive to us or what we were
happiest about is that we actually are
recovering these low affinity
interactions down here above the
background so this gives us the first
indication that we can use this type of
approach to recover low affinity
interactions just above the background
using this sort of selection approach
now this I wanted to put this up here to
let you know that we can do this kind of
thing with protein-dna interactions but
everything else that I'm going to talk
about is protein protein interactions so
we have converted the system now to look
at protein-protein interactions just
like any two hybrid sa what we're doing
is we take a DNA binding domain with
known specificity and express one
protein we take the other protein and
express it as a fusion with Omega our
activation domain we've started out by
using pdz domains because these are very
well characterized protein domains that
bind to the c-terminus of their
interacting partners so there's a
mountain of literature for us to compare
what we're doing to and you know
validate the way that our system is
working so the first one we're working
with here is the urban pdz domain again
there are many publications documenting
how urban binds with its interacting
partner that we can use to validate the
system so just like the DNA binding
interaction the first thing that we did
was a proof of concept where we tested
urban with a number of different ligands
that have previously been tested to show
decreases in relative folds of affinity
based on these substitutions in the
ligands that the pdz domain binds to and
you can see we're getting a nice
relationship between our gfp expression
and the known decreases in affinity of
the urban ligand interaction again we're
excited that we're capturing these
interactions down here that are a
significant decrease in affinity
relative to the consensus target and
we're still getting this signal above a
negative control right here and this is
becoming it's more evident that this is
important because we've tested the
c-terminal peptides from known
interacting partners of urban so these
are our proteins that we know urban
interacts with in vivo we took their
peptides express them in the system and
you can see we get this gfp expression
that is above our negative control but
it's very low activity so these are
arbitrary units of gfp in the low
hundreds sort of range and if we go back
to this slide that's you're talking
about this range down here so when we
measure what's going on between urban
and these known interacting partners
these are very low affinity interactions
and we're just happy that we're able to
recover those but at this point you know
what we've been talking about are
one-to-one interactions that we've set
up what we'd ultimately like to be able
to do is screen through libraries so the
first library that we built was
completely randomizing the last seven
amino acids or the c-terminal side
venenum amino acids of a protein we have
this library we're testing it but I'm
not going to show you anything that
we've done with it because I big a more
informed library that we built has been
in collaboration with one of our
collaborators at the University of
Toronto Phil Kim who created this
library by taking by designing over
50,000 peptides that all come from human
proteins or different splice variants
from human proteins so it becomes a more
manageable size for us to look through
and sequence and find out exactly what's
going on here in plus it's relevant to
the what urban would actually bind to in
a human cell so the first comparison
that I have here is between a low
stringency selection that we did with
this library and phage display results
and while you can tell that we're we're
moving towards the consensus sequence
that you would find with phage display
we're recovering a lot more diversity
here and I really want to highlight this
minus one position because what we find
when we go back to these things that
we've tested before
that there are substitutions and all of
the known interactions at this minus one
position none of them have tryptophan at
that position and if we go back to this
one you can see you know when we
substitute make substitutions at the
minus one position these are very low
affinity interactions so that implies
that you know what we're recovering in
this very low stringency selection is a
very wide range of affinities from
substitutions or low affinity at on the
minus one position all the way up to the
consensus target now if we want to lead
to yeah
yeah yeah yeah Oh what else I'll throw
it a caveat here so we've just started
doing these selections there actually is
an alumina run going on these things are
based off of about 20 to 30 sequences so
that might just be a sampling difference
I can't tell you why the difference
would be for phage display why they're
not getting any leucine but only
isoleucine but you know maybe we would
find more isoleucine it would make sense
that you would find both really but okay
so all of these different logos that i'm
going to show you our based on 20 to 30
sequences though we'll soon have you
know millions of sequence reads okay so
if we want to get closer to a consensus
all we have to do is increase the
stringency of the selection and all of a
sudden you know we get a much stronger
interaction but that's not the point
here is we want to actually grab the low
end of affinity and then tell us what
that means so since this was a selection
we know that these things survive the
threshold that we said we don't know if
there's a difference between the
peptides that we select so that's where
gfp comes in is that we can then start
to tease out are there differences in
these things that met our threshold so
the process that we are now taking is we
we do a selection where we provide a
very minimal level of 380 or a minimal
selection and what I mean by that how we
set this level is we take our library
without a protein interaction and start
with no 380 and start to increase it
until the cells don't survive anymore so
we get to the lowest point possible
where you know the cells would survive
without a protein interaction and that's
the threshold that we said it's usually
about point five millimeter 380 which
for anything else we've done is an
incredibly low stringency so we recover
everything on this plate we pull it
together we take a cent as a sample
sequence of that pool and then we just
sort it out by gfp and recover different
pools at increasing gfp levels so with
urban this is what you get we've
recovered populations at increasing gfp
cons
trations and you can see that we're
moving towards the consensus sequence as
we look at higher expression levels of
GFP but what's interesting to me is even
at this very low level of GSP output
we're still seeing some hallmarks of the
urban specificity we're still seeing the
valine down here we're seeing in the
Civic residue followed by a three Indian
or a serine you know but we're we're
recovering a bunch of diversity as well
so we think that that's interesting but
I another thing I wanted to point out
was that this population is actually
below this GFP threshold that we set and
I think we're doing this for a reason
and that's because this threshold is
just done set by some negative control
but when we've looked at for example
these interactions before it's not like
the expression level is way above the
mean of a negative control it's just
barely above that mean so what we're
actually doing is we're starting to we
start collecting populations at the mean
of the negative control and move above
there okay so so where do we actually
find these interactions these low
affinity interactions and the
populations that we recover we're
actually finding specific or we're
finding these actual peptides and low
counts in the low in the medium gfp
output we never find them in the high
gfp output so again when we submit some
sort of a selection like this we're only
finding the low-affinity interactions in
the loggia p output this is the same
when we look at other pdz domains where
you see this increase in a trend towards
the consensus when we look at a mag 3
pdz domain we've scaled up now we've
looked at 12 other pdz domains but what
I want to make clear about what our
ultimate approach will be we don't have
our Illumina's results back yet so we
can't actually tell you exactly what is
in all of these pools the point that I
want to make is that the comparisons
that we're going to be able to make
between this starting sequence here and
different pools will be very informative
where we will be able to reduce or
eliminate the bias that could be in this
starting sample by because all of these
different GFP outputs would have started
from the same place and the other thing
that we're doing is we're looking at
different time points so we look at one
time point of gfp output then we look
another six hours later and we're
actually check we're testing or we're
measuring how the gfp level is changing
for any given peptide does it go for how
quickly is it going from you know the
low GFP output to the medium low gfp
output and that speed is telling us
something about the affinity or at least
that's how we we hope this is going to
pan out okay so in summary it's becoming
more and more importers more and more
evident that low affinity interactions
are very important interactions in vivo
but most of the methods that we use have
difficulty capturing that low end of a
functional affinity we hope that by
combining these selectable and scalable
reporters that we can recover the low
end of affinity functional low end of
affinity and then by comparing the
enrichment of these peptides over across
different GFP populations ultimately
we'd like to be able to make claims
about relative affinities for all
peptides that protein is able to
interact with the people that did this
work I think I went through this very
quickly but that means we have plenty of
time for questions the people that did
this work we the people in my lab that
actually set up a lot of these systems
at Princeton are elizabeth bennet denise
van is now a graduate student here at
berkeley and Jennifer Doudna slab and
amazingly the amount of a pdz domain
work that I've showed here was all done
in a single rotation by xu wei who is an
amazing graduate student so if there if
anyone has advice about how to bribe
someone to join your lab we'd appreciate
it because she's awesome and then dave
has also helped out in
setting up this system so I'll take any
questions random language either the
nucleotide all the peptide are going to
cover all the cameras we have a sense of
what sequence of you okay so in the
original DNA library that we tested in
Scotts lab it's a 28 base pair fragment
and we the library sizes two times ten
to the eighth so it's nowhere near
covering every possible combination but
the way I looked at it was we are likely
if you think of a 28 base pair region as
you know 16 overlapping 12 base pair
regions you know you could think of it
as overlapping 12 base pair libraries
and we would actually cover that in two
times ten of eight so that's my weak way
of claiming that we were covering all 12
verse but no I you know Scott could have
sequence the entire library by now
because ten to the eighth would not back
when we first made that library it was
impossible to sequence but now you could
actually sequence tenderly you know so
so no we don't we don't actually know
the the large seven amino acid peptide
library that we've created we actually
built it to be 10 to the temp so it was
a very arduous process to build it but
we you know obviously we can't actually
sequence all of the variants but we made
a huge library also be sure that thought
well you can capture the door is stuck
and you know what's there when they
initially the ranking
what's the collation there is some
transformation 15 yep we don't know yet
I mean that's what we're hoping to find
and what it's going to take like I was
just alluding to at the end it's
probably going to take recovering
populations and multiple time points to
actually figure out you know how the
population is changing at different gfp
levels over time to tell us how that's
really relating to gfp and if there is
an exact transformation between gfp and
the infinity yeah yeah I don't know I
mean that would be you know the holy
holy grail for me is to actually be able
to produce KD values with this I think
what we will probably end up having is
relative some relative score you know
like this is some you know you x factor
of the the consensus target or the eyes
yes yeah
what the chip
give me in sequence um yeah yeah based
on we count yeah well Wow I see what
you're saying so get the counts of the
different peptides that are in the
different well we sort of get that when
we when we do the high-throughput
sequencing you know we're going to get
sequence reads for each each protein so
I mean we don't really need to barcode
it to get that right like gfp level
right why don't you have something to
pay again just so you can see
oh I see what you're saying so we could
actually sequence how much mRNA is being
expressed rather than looking at the
fluorescence itself um that well we
hadn't thought about that that's a
that's a good idea no no no because I
mean there there's actually one of the
issues that we're having setting up the
system by the way we haven't even come
close to publishing any of so you know
don't tell anyone um provides oh wait
it's oh no buddy cop eNOS but you know
one of the problems that you have is at
some point you just max out gfp
expression you know you hit a maximal
but mrna levels it's different right so
that's it that's a good suggestion that
we could correlate it to the actual
amount of G appear RNA that's being
expressed
me and then don't go and be aware where
there's another whole reception at four
so you can go have coffee now but you
know more food thank you again